Harry Potter fans are wishing that JK
Rowling author of the novels upon which
the film series is based would use the
silencing charm on herself wait was that
Harry Potter reference it most
definitely was on June 6 2020 Rowling
posted several tweets subtly and not so
subtly sharing her opinions about
transgender people many have considered
Rowling's comments to be hurtful and
sensitive and transphobic including the
biggest Harry Potter star there is her
tweets prompted a response and an
apology to the transgender community
from Daniel Radcliffe who portrayed the
boy who lived in all eight Harry Potter
movies Harry Potter this isn't the first
time that Rowling is decided to take to
Twitter to call the notion of
transgender people into question even
though she has no medical experience or
education that anybody is aware of in
December 2019 Rowling tweeted her
support for some ignorant statements
made by Maya for stater a discredited
researcher at a London think-tank whose
views on the trans experience were
deemed by British courts as being quotes
not worthy of respect in a democratic
society standing up in defense of the
maligned researcher Rowling tweeted at
the time dress however you please call
yourself whatever you like sleep with
any consenting adults who will have you
live your best life in peace and
security but force women out of their
jobs for stating that sex is real I
stand with Maya this is not a drill the
backlash to the sweep from Rowling's
fans who have long found messages of
inclusivity understanding and
enlightenment and Rowling's work came
fast and furious but the author remained
largely silent on the subject until now
unfortunately she has only broken her
silence to double down a response to an
op-ed article that used the descriptor
people who menstruate Rowling tweeted
people who men straight I'm sure there
used to be a word for those people
someone help me out one Ben wimp and mud
not to be rude or anything but this
isn't a great time demonstrating a
marvelous ability to embody the ideals
championed by his character Radcliffe
quickly responded with a post published
on the website for The Trevor Project
which provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services for LGBTQ
youth Radcliffe took a brief moment to
acknowledge Rowling's pivotal role in
giving him a career he also issued a
brief disclaimer that despite how it's
sure to be perceived by the press he
wasn't looking to start a fight with the
author Danny started dropping truth
bombs
Radcliffe wrote in his statement
transgender women are women any
statement to the Khan
Prarie erases the identity and dignity
of transgender people and goes against
all advice given by professional health
care associations who have far more
expertise on the subject matter than
either Joe or I the actor then shared a
few statistics and educational resources
before addressing the Potter fandom
directly to all the people who feel that
their experience of the books has been
tarnished or diminished I am deeply
sorry for the pain these comments have
caused you if you found anything in
these stories that resonated with you
and helped you at any time in your life
then that is between you and the book
that you read and it is sacred and in my
opinion nobody can touch that among
Harry Potter pants on Twitter the
response the radcliffe's post was
spontaneous and spot-on forget JK
Rowling the entire fandom seemed to
decide all at once let's just pretend
that Daniel Radcliffe wrote the Harry
Potter books and go back to enjoying
them problem solved this appeared to
open the floodgates for users who don't
tolerate transphobia but are keen on
deadpan humor as one poster put it isn't
it amazing that Daniel Radcliffe both
wrote and starred in Harry Potter
he's like the lin-manuel miranda
wizardry user cricket Spillane jumped in
with I can't believe Daniel Radcliffe
wrote all seven Harry Potter books and
starred in all eight film adaptations he
is truly unbelievable perhaps the best
exchange of them all after Twitter user
thy kingdom scum popped into Marvel that
Daniel Radcliffe was only eight years
old when he wrote the Harry Potter books
trivia accounts what the f fax countered
Sir Isaac Newton was only 23 when he
discovered the law of gravity leave it
to Twitter to find such an elegant
solution to a thorny situation also well
done mr. Radcliffe ten points for
Gryffindor if you or someone you know
are LGBTQ and are in crisis or are in
need of a safe space to talk check out
the trevor projects website or call the
trevor lifeline at one eight six six
four eight eight seven three eight six
[Music]